on reçoit je vous dis
Riel la star de French Histor euh je
vous dis c'est un truc de fou on reçoit
Ouriel mais aussi Antonin tu vois
candidat emblématique des Marseillais et
boss de la villa dans frenchtore qui
sont avec nous dans un instant on va
regarder la bandeannon c'est une
nouvelle téléréalité qui passe sur
Paramount je Paramount s'est fait
connaître juste grâce à ça un truc de
fou connaissais pas du tout voilà je
connaissais par rapou je connaissais
tout je connaissais pas donc bravo à eux
quand même beaucoup et on va regarder la
bande annonce et vous allez voir
pourquoi cette
téléréalité vraiment fait trembler les
politiques et fait trembler tout le
monde parce que c'est vrai que quand
onarde ce qui arrive sur à la télé quand
on voit ça on se dit là on a passé un
cap et comment vous voulez que
téléréalité Mar ça c'est terminé
regardz
[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous merci beaucoup
ourriel et merci beaucoup Antonin ça va
bien merci à vous très bien merci à
toi parle que de vous j'adore moi
j'adore franchement j'adore je suis fan
ben merci beaucoup tant mieux bravo et
moi j'aime bien les trucs bousculent
voilà les les codes et vous avez
bousculé les codes ça fait des années
qu'on dit que la
téléréalité les chaînes traditionnelles
ont essayé sont toutes prises des des
bananes flambées euh c'est des trucs que
des trucs de mergueise voilà et là enfin
avec frenchore on voit un vrai bail
qu'on attendait depuis des années qui va
plus loin ce qu'on a déjà vu alors il y
en a plein qui s'insurge comme dans tout
ce qui marche he vous inquiétez pas si
vous marchez pas personne viendrait vous
chercher il est vrai vous savez c'est
comme moi si j'étais pas beau gosse
personne non non mais je vous le dis
faut arrêter voilà c'est c'est moi je
trouve que c'est exceptionnel et c'est
vrai que ça choque beaucoup Gilles
pourquoi ça choque avant qu'on parle
avec auiel et Antonin ça choque sur le
plan moral parce que il y a pas de
limite c'estàdire que Don donne-nous des
DD il y a une sexualité débridée c'est
des gens qui assument totalement d'être
purement sexuel d'être trans d'être B
d'être dans toutes les positions
sexuelles et en fait ça fait paniquer
tout le monde parce que comme c'est géré
en Allemagne si tout comme comme c'est
géré Paramout est en Allemagne d'accord
c'est-à-dire que l'autorité française de
régulation ne peut pas intervenir donc
là on est face à un dépassement de
toutes les limites vous avez dit
bousculer les chaînes traditionnelles ne
savent plus comment réagir et le
gouvernement les politiques
s'interrogent en disant pourquoi
pourquoi ça cartonne pourquoi les jeunes
regardent ça est-ce que c'est la société
qui nous échappe donc sur tous les plans
moral économique télévisuel c'est
panique à bord Cyril c'est c'est un
programme qui réinvente quelque part la
télévision voilà mais c'est ouais ou non
mais c'est en réalité un faux procès
parce qu'on parlait tout à l'heure du
porno qui accessible partout il respecte
quand même certaines limites parce que
c'est pas vraiment un problème
pornographique c'est plus érotique il y
a quand même des limites qui son respect
mi c'est drôle c'est divertissant il a
un casting de dingue Auel ça fait très
longtemps qu'on avait pas une aussi
grosse star issue d'émission téléalité
et franchement c'est c'est un plaisir à
regarder et ça cartonne sur les réseaux
les vidéos elles font 10 15 millions de
vues c'est incroyable franchement bien
joué param bien jou c'est vrai alors
mais le truc c'est qui regarde en
fait jeun est-ce que c'est des quadrats
en mal de frisson non non
jeou c'est des jeunes de quel âge en
fait est-ce que c'est des jeunes de 10
ans est-ce que vous avez envie de que
votre fils regarde ça par exemple mon
fils ou vous auriez envie qu'il regarde
ça on n pas la télé on pas internet on
pas internet
on le papa ou la maman regarde mais est
que l'enfant accè ce n'est pas destiné
aux enfants
logoage il y a précision qu' a des
caractères qui sont explicites et donc
sur MTV c'est Mo 18 et par 16 c'est un
programme précis qui cible une audience
précise et nous Candat on dit c'est pas
aux enfants et ça unot d'ordre dus ce
qu'on fait c'est très débridé et c'est
pas tout le monde par peu avec eu avant
vous donz votre avis vous êtes très
gentil et j'ai des gens que je
reçois est-ce que vous pouvez nous
parler de vous parce que vousel vous
êtes la star du programme vous avez quel
âge apparemment 25 ans 25 ans faites
quoi dans la vie et dans la vie j'ai
fait plusieurs jobs comme n'importe quel
jeune qui veut gagner sa vie et puis il
y a eu l'opportunité de French SH qui
est arrivé et puis qu'est-ce qu'on vous
a dit sur French SH au départ on vous a
dit il faut faire quoi alors French SH
on m'a tout simplement dit que c'était
comme les formats américains jers short
Jordy short donc dès le départ on était
informé que ça allait être une émission
beaucoup plus trash complètement
différente de ce qu'on a déjà vu en
France habituellement donc dès le départ
on était dans le bain je savais où je
mettais les pis alors vous vous êtes on
a la parlé tout à l'heure vous êtes TR
jour c'est ça exactement c'est ça vous
avez tout de suite adhéré au concept bah
tout de suite parce que c'est vrai que
j'ai personnalité assez flamboyante j'ai
une manière d'être de vivre et je
voulais pas faire de la télé pour faire
de la télé si un jour je faisais de la
télé je voulais un prrme où je puiss
être moi-même il vous ont pris parce que
pourquoi vous pensez qu'ils vous ont
choisi alors là ils nont pas pris parce
que j'étais trans gen il vou je sais que
la question revient souvent non parce
que euh quand ils m'ont prise ils me
l'ont dit la production moi je l'ai dit
au deuxième épisode que j'étais une
femme trans mais la production m'a dit
si tu ne veux même ne pas le dire du
tout tu peux ne pas le dire ils m'ont
pris parce que je suis extravertie parce
que j'assume mes pensées mes propos que
je suis très àaise avec mon corp et ça
justement pourquoi vous votre portrait
dans mon portrait pardon votre portrait
vous dites quoi dans mon portrait ça
coûte très cher les images oui je dis
des je dis des choses d'une manière un
peu crue comme quoi je suis une femme
assumée ouais j'aime que j'assume aimer
le sexe que c'est quelque chose a quoi
je suis à l'aise que j'aime les hommes
j'en joue beaucoup c'est vrai que le
portrait mon portrait a fait beaucoup
parler en tout cas parce que je dis les
choses très crues c'est pour ça que
c'est bien aussi quoi sans le S c'est un
peu vulgaire c'est il y a des phrases un
peu drôles du C du culuc des trucs drôes
des trucs fun c'est des trucs fun en
fait c'est la manière que j'ai de parler
peut être brute mais j'ai toujours fait
beaucoup de second degré non mais oui
c'est pas la chose la plus incroyable
que j'ai pu dire de ma vie je le conçois
c'est toi c'est toi qui a écrit ton
texte non non c'est moi qui écrit mon
texte j'ai pas écrit j'ai pas pris un
livre en écrivant duul tu chapeau pointu
do dans ton cul exactement ça vient de
moi signorriel ah oui d'accord bravo
faudrait que tu fasses des citations a
plaisir non mais juste pour rebondir mon
portrait fait beaucoup parler mais c'est
vrai que l'image très sexuelle que je
donne je ne suis pas que ça et c'est
pour ça que c'est important pour moiir
sur des plateau et d'en parler parce que
c'est pas parce qu'on est une femme
assumée qui aime la sexualité bien dans
son corps et là-bas alors comment ça
s'est passé alors alors tuas tuas tuas
tu as eu des des relations oui je pense
que les premiers épisodes ont parlé de
de M on pas vu oui j'ai j'ai eu des
relation effectivement assez assumée
direct direct tu pas direct je pense au
bout du du 4è jour ah ça va oui
j'aiattendu un petit peu 3 jours ça
va après une fois que s'était lancé
après merci beaucoup donc c'est quoi ton
histoire c'est quoi son histoire là-bas
c'est tu as fait tu tu étais avec
quelqu'un après quoi tuas non après il y
a pas vraiment de ligne de conduite on
est 10 jeunes qui venont faire la fête
on est tous très débridés on est tous
très assumés les choses se font
naturellement les uns vont avec les
autres des binômes secrés et puis en
fait il se passe tout ce qui peut se
passer en vacances avec 10 potes qui
profitont det excusez-moi excusez-moi
attendez je fais parler de secondes à la
r il me fatigue c'est combien les images
sans les cil par qu'on est curieux quand
même 1000 € jamais je l'ai
mets un fou il me dit c'est bon tu peux
mettre les images sans les compil c'est
pas cher dis 1000 € tu c je mettre 1000
€ c'est bon elle va nous raconter on a
compris ou j'ai une question pour donc
vous l'avez dit vous êtes une femme
trans genreou vous le dites pas au début
de de l'aventure en tout cas pas à vous
colocataires et en fait vous faites
votre coming out on dit c'est ça ouais
c'est ça exactement ce qui est une
séquence très forte très émouvante à un
moment où on a l'impression qu'il va se
passer quelque chose avec un garçon pour
le prévenir est-ce que c'est une réalité
ça dans votre vie est-ce que c'est une
éthique entre guillemets que vous avez
de prévenir le garçon ou vous ne pouvez
ne pas le faire alors si de manière
générale c'est bien de prévenir le
partenaire avec qui tu es de manière
générale c'est toujours mieux après
voilà ça dépend du type de relation et
cetera mais sans rentrer dans le débat
de ma vie privée dans l'émission c'est
important de un parce que je vais
fréquenter des hommes et je veux qu'il
me fréquentent en ayant conscience de
qui je suis et de deux le but aussi
c'était de faire évoluer les mentalités
les femmes trans très peu représenté
dans la téléréalité donc c'était de de
décomplexer démocratiser la
transidentité tu peux être une femme
trans et vivre ta vie tout simplement
donc c'est pour ça que je l'ai dit
rapidement et je voulais pas coucher
devant les caméras avec des garçons et
ça prenent après je trouvais pas ça
hyper réglo qu'est-ce qui choque dans
cette téléréalité Jean-Michel bah non
c'est qu'il y a des des positions sont
assez explicites quoi il y a des images
où dans les anciennes téléréalités on
les voyait dans le noir c'était filmé en
infrarouge sous la on voyait la couette
qui bougeit c'était le grand ça y est on
disait ça y est c'est c'est le drame il
y a du cul sur sur M6 et cetera alors
que là maintenant on voit carrément les
positions dans le parce que ça se passe
au sud au vu de tout le monde c'est ça
peut être il peut avoir une fation dans
le salon devant les autres candidats ah
oui c'est le CL d' du cul quoi oui AC cl
anglaise avec la CL anglaise ave la clé
anglaise et donc voilà ça se passe au vu
de tout le monde et tous les autres
rigolent à côté il se parlent et Cera
alors c'est un peu flouté mais on voit
quand même les actes quoi donc c'est
quand même c'est
explicite ce qui choque aussi c'est
c'est les fl qui sont parfois un peu
légers et on voit les parties intimes
parfois on les voit beaucoup mais c'est
fait je sais pas d'une manière un peu
humoristique où il y a une deuxème
lecture c'est pas un film pornographique
c'est plus intelligent que ça je
trouveou parce que toute façon si les
jeunes veulent voir du vraiment du porno
ils vont sur internet a foison de sit
internet qui sont beaucoup plus trashes
là c'est quand même il y a d'autres
codes qui sont qui correspondent aux
jeunes et qui sont voilà qui sont appr
prendre au second degré deg moi je pense
que ce qui pose problème c'est que ça
fait des années que la téléréalité est
en train d'essayer de devenir de plus en
plus softe et de plus en plus régulier
et qu'en fait là vous vous bousculez
tous les codes et vous dites merde vous
le feriez alors non mais mais parce que
j'ai mon intimité reste mon intimité
mais j'ai aucun problème avec ce qui
s'est passé et j'ai trouvé que ce qui
était très bien dans ton coming out j'ai
pas regardé du tout mais j'ai vu ton
coming out j'ai trouvé que c'était très
beau parce que il y a personne qui s'est
attardé sur le sujet c'estàd qu'en fait
on s'est dit ok elle a dit qu'elle était
trans ok cool on passe à autre chose et
il y avait pas de il y avait pas
vraiment on en fait un dossier on en
fait un truc vous faire une petite gâie
un candidat dans toutes les pièces de la
maison euh un peu si comme si vous vous
êtes un petit peu le le Stéphan flazza
euh c'est vrai est-ce que ant est-ce que
vous pouvez nous parler de cette sé par
que vous êtes le le voilà vous êtes
quand même le boss de la Villa ben en
fait pour rebondir un petit peu sur ce
que disait Jean-Michel moi j'ai plus de
20 TL réalité à mon actif donc pour moi
c'est pas des extraterrestes plus forte
cl oui celle-là oui c'est de loin c'est
la plus forte mais c'est pas des
extratrestes ceux qu'il font dans la
téléréalité euh moi j'ai pu le voir le
côtoyer dans d'autres programmes
seulement c'était pas diffusé parce que
c'était pas aux mêmes horreurs donc au
rel c'est pour moi c'est pas une
extraterrestre je j'admire son alors je
vous confirme des extr ce n'est pas une
extraterrestre confirme je je vous le
confirme et et et donc alors non mais
c'est vrai que dans l'émission donc
c'était quoi cette idée là de faire
toutes les pièces comme ça non
honnêtement c'est pas une idée c'est
c'est vrai que là c'est filmé alors déjà
il faut savoir que nous on est beaucoup
filmé sous caméra fixe donc les camarads
ne sont pas souvent avec nous donc nous
on est vraiment entre nous et en VIIe VI
entre caméas fixe mais le garçon j'a
l'impression qu'il avait la barre fixe
oui c'est oui merci cy effectivement
mais non c'est pas une idée honnêtement
c'est un extrait qui a fait qui a été
beaucoup vu j'étais avec un garçon que
je fréquentais à ce momentl et puis on a
eu des des rapports ensemble et ça s'est
fait à différents endroits mais bon
attends je vais te dire quand tu as une
grande maison bah c'est ça non mais
c'est vrai tu VO regarde j'ai non mais
je te jure voilà je je peux le
comprendre je peux le comprendre vous
avez combien de pièges chez
vous non mais moi alors non mais j'ai
arrêté moi je je mange pas de ce pain là
c'est une simple question je te dis bah
là tu es dans la merde tu veux que je
dis je pense que estce que tuas un plus
grand un plus grand appart que moi je ne
pense pas non ce ou je suis dans un F2
et vous F2 oui oui F20 F20
F2 quoi j'ai un 80 m² 75 le salon la
salle de bain 80 mais les autres pièces
Dr est con déménager connard bon alors
on vous voit souvent très voit très
souvent
nu ou alors avec très peu de tissu vous
n'aviez pas fait votre
valise merci merci merci s soucier
j'avais plein d'affaires je vous rassure
j'avais plein d' faire maintenant
effectivement j'étais cette personne un
peu désinhibée de la Ve là il fait chaud
on était entre nous et c'est vrai que
j'étais souvent nu et je suis à l'aise
avec ma nudité donc j'ai aucun problème
avec ça même si ça peut choquer les gens
et ça je le conçois choque avec ça
personnellement oui oui moi ce qui m'a
enfin ce qui m'a interpellé c'est qu'à
l'heure on se pose beaucoup de questions
sur le consentement sur les agressions
sur Mitou et cetera là on réunit une
bande de jeunes qui aiment le sexe et
qui l'assume on leur dit en gros faites
ce que vous voulez est-ce que vous en
tant que femme et les autres femmes
aussi de l'aventure vous avez pas eu
peur à des moments qu' y a des dérapages
non alors quoi qu'il en soit ça reste
une émission qui encadrée ouais est-
just pas du tout absolument pas alors ça
pour le coup on peut dire vraiment déjà
un gros bravo au casteur les 10
personnes que soi les femmes ou les
hommes étai des personnes très
respectueuses très humains et
honnêtement on était vraiment tous
incroyabl entre nous maintenant oui la
question peut se poser il y avait un
conscentement qui était incroyable il y
a jamais eu de choses faites sans
l'accord d'autrui là on le voit d'une
manière très explicite mais il faut
savoir que un épisode résumé en 60
minutes c'est 48 he de tournage donc
c'est un condensé de choses mais on a
des discussions en interne quand même on
n pas juste oui moi c'était juste je
en fait dans ça me choque pas
particulièrement l'émission je trouve
que ça peut être un petit peu
problématique au niveau des plus jeunes
qui voi des extraits sur les réseaux
sociaux et cetera mais en fait j'ai
trouvé que par exemple j'ai regardé la
téléité quand j'étais au collège lycée
et je regardais les émissions que tu
faisais et je trouvais que l'image de la
fan était plus dégradante dans tes
émissions dans les émissions dans
lesquelles tu faisais les Marseillais et
cetera plutôt que dans une émission où
en fait les femmes elles sont libres
elles disent oui j'aime le cul mais
c'est comme ça c'est très très power
ouais vraiment c'est plus c'est plus le
fait que des enfants puissent tomber
dessus mopocrisie c'est ça que j'aim moi
je déteste un truc c'est l'hypocrisie
vous le saurez he y a maintenant et je
déteste l'hypocrisie et là il y a pas
d'hypocrisie dansémission non mais je le
dis voilà on dit j'aime le cucu j'aime
le cucu voilà oui alors comme tout le
monde s'extasie je vais casser
l'ambiance et je vousouve AB tu casses
l'ambiance avec T gilet là je trouve
absolument
sympathique du crochet c'est du crochet
pardon mag je crois pas bon bref et je
vous trouve absolument charmante et
j'adore ce que vous dites et voilà donc
ça me plaît beaucoup je voulais juste
vous poser trois questions est-ce que je
trouve que vous êtes très alcoaolisé
dans le programme j'ai l'impression donc
ça je trouve que c'est moyen ça veut
dire que ça sous-entend que en gros pour
être désinhibé pour avoir envie de cul
pour faire n'importe quoi on a besoin
d'être alcoolisé je trouve que c'est un
très bah c'est pas une réalité pour tout
le monde mais c'est parce que tous les
je excuse-moi c'est un très signal on
peut aussi être très très bien dans son
corps et tout ça sans être forcémentè h
bravo Gald c'est pas hypocrite par que
toi d'alcool mais je dis c'est une
réalité que les jeunes font des
soir responsable et je n'aime pas j'aime
pas ce signal là voilà ça c'est la
première chose mais c'est pas parce que
la plupart des jeunes qu'on doit dire ah
bah ok la plupart des jeunes bon on a
qu' biturer c'est très bien il y a pas
de problème deuxème chose est-ce que
vous mettez des capotes oui tous les
rapports ont été consentis protég pour a
un distributeur là bah déjà oui on a à
disposition mais chacun moi
personnellement je le dis j'avais pris
mes précautions et j'avais ramené des
préserva façon ils en
don et tous les test on av tous été
dépistés aux IST avant de faire
l'émission
trsr est-ce que c'est vachement dit dans
le programme parce que moi je trouve que
ce serait vachement bien que ce soit dit
en amont par que juste voilà je trouve
qu'il y aurait un truc vraiment de
pédagogie parce qu'on parle aujourd'hui
de ce programme là comme un truc
beaucoup plus inclusif beaucoup plus
modne qui protège beaucoup plus les
femmes les hommes et tout ça moi le je
m'en fous il y a rien qui me choque donc
tout va bien mais je trouve qu'il y
aurait une responsabilité c'estàdire
qu'on peut faire n'importe quoi
justement après si justement en amont on
a dit bah on n'est pas forcément
complètement ivreemort et on pe
est préservou Paron c'est quoi la
troisième chose ma chérie ah parce que
je vais pas assz vite et la troisème
chose ouais non parce qu'on disait c'est
formidable c'est inclusif c'est beaucoup
moins sexiste que les autres programmes
ouais enfin il faut pas quand même
exagérer il y a quand même exactement
les mêmes stéréotypes en gros quand une
fille est facile ou quand elle veut
coucher en gros ou elle embrasse un mec
à 15h et puis un autre mec à 16h c'est
une [__] alors que le gars il a le
droit et il a enfin il a tous les droits
on on reproduit exactement les mêmes
clichers c'est juste que c'est un petit
peu plus tr Daniel arrête de regarder
comme ça tu VO on parle pas de toi non
parce que pour attends 2 minutes 2
minutes lui al lui il est tout
excité
inéress maisal
calme-toi dois te calmer tu dois te
calmer pour des raisons non c'est gentil
mais juste par rapport à l'alcool c'est
important de le dire l'alcool était pas
cétait pas limité beaucoup toi beaucoup
honnêtement dans la vie tous les jours
je bois pas énormément soir exactement
et la production stopper l'alcool on on
a jamais été dans des étatraes complèes
et la majorité merci ou la majorité des
images qu'on voit on est tous très
foufou on n pas vu d'alcool donc en fait
on a un casting très dévergondé de base
et c'est vrai que l'alcool ça donne un
côté foufou mais ça n'a rien changé à ça
et par rapport au côté des femmes où
effectivement il y a ce côté un peu
sexiste les femmes on était beaucoup
plus pionnière de la sexualité dans la
maison que les hommes c'est pas nous qui
courons derrière les hommes il y avait
un côté beaucoup plus ambassadeur de la
part des femmes que des hommes au niveau
de la sexualité et effectivement il y a
ce côté toujours mais quand elle court
après la sexualité on les traite quand
même malgré toutop oui par contre je
suis d'accord ou sur les réseaux moi qui
même stéréot moi qui fait des choses
sexuelles je suis plus accablé qu'un
homme qui aura fait des choses pas ça
t'arvera ou est-ce que ça te choque ça
moi ça me choque parce que voilà vous
êtes entre adulte consentant donc tout
va bien mais c'est en libre consommation
je suis un peu non c'est payant non non
mais mais arrivve à le voir forcément
voilà les jeunes je parle ça me dérange
et et j'ai une question on a parlé
d'alcool la drogue est-ce que c'est très
un sujet tabou est-ce que c'était très
interd aucun sujet tabou c'était zéro
c'était hors de question de toute façon
comme toute émission les Valis sont
fouillé de la tête au pied et ça par
contre je l'assure à aucun moment il n a
eu de la drogue et aucun des candidats
éta intéressé de toute manière par pas
du tout Daniel voilà RA de poser la
question
bravo Dani
dragib ou j'essaie de décrocher mais
c'est quand même un peu le bal des
hypocrites parce que moi je me dis que
si j'avais 20 ans on met 10 jeunes dans
une villa avec des meufs avec de
l'alcool avec des potes j'y vais tout de
suite faire le chariste et le
manutentionnaire charger des palettes je
serai parti tout de suite donc déjà là
il y a un premier point d'hypocrisie et
le deuxième point d'hypocrisie c'est ce
qui ceux
qui c'est l'hypocrisie on aurait tous
été à 20 ans il y en a beaucoup oui toi
non mais il y en a beaucoup je vais
citer un je vais citer quelqu'un toi tu
le fais à 5 an je vais citer quelqu'un
20 ans rien n'est impossible à 20 ans on
est invincible qui a dit
ça non mais il y a déjà première
hypocrisie c'est celll la plupart des
gens ils auraient peut-être voulu aussi
y aller si ça existait quand ils avaient
20 ans oui mais pas toi Dani moi je suis
hnte je dis 20s ser ven VO quand tu
avais 20 ans ils étaient dans des
diligences les
gars quoi tué ça faisait dans un Saloun
frère tu CIS quoi mais on parle pas de
toi et la deuxème hypocrisie c'est c'est
les personnes qui veulent interdire ce
programme qui se trouve auusqué c'est un
programme qui est interdit c'est
interdit au moins 18 ans c'est sur une
plateforme c'est sur une
chaînep ça fait 20 ans queit même plus
de 20 ans qu'il y a georgechor personne
n' a
parlé
c'est je vous dise e bravo moi je dis
bravo à ceux qui ont fait ça ou bravo à
vous et bravo à paramon voilà je vous le
dis et on est et je vous le dis et les
autres là les chaînes là qui veulent
faire leur truc là de ringard ils sont
complètement à côté de la plaque c'est
des trucs de gaz mer ça voilà je dis
c'est des gaz mer total qui sont en
train de préparer là et je le dis ça me
fait pas plaisir je le dis mais c'est
des guaz mer par rapport à ça c'est pas
aujourd'hui quand tu vois ça ça
aujourd'hui en fait c'est le seul truc
qui peuter euh ce que tu vois sur TikTok
euh ce que tu vois voilà sur les réseaux
c'est le seul truc qui peut contrer le
reste je vais vous dire si tu vas mettre
des gars et j'adore la Star Academy
c'est très sympa mais deux gars qui vont
te chanter Jean-Jacques Goldman je
marche au solul dans un château frère je
m'en bat les couilles mais je une force
mon frère non mais je t'explique non
mais vraiment on s'en bat les steaks non
mais je te dis ce qu'on veut voir c'est
ça voilà ça c'est ce qu'on veut voir
aujourd'hui c'est on a on peut pas les
gars on peut pas faire des émissions qui
étaient là il y a 20 ans faire
exactement la même chose mais si voilà
c'est très bien et c'est très beau mais
aujourd'hui c'est où les chaînes
prennent des risques et le problème
c'est que sur des chaînes normales tu
pouras jamais voir ça je vais vous dire
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui à part sur
C8 par exemple on peut pas faire une
émission aussi moderne que TPMP sur une
autre chaîne parce que nous on a la
chance d'avoir un patron exceptionnel on
a une grosse liberté de ton je vous dis
aujourd'hui TPMP ça pourrait être nul
par ailleurs quand je vois les mergesses
que font TF1 je vous dis la vérité je
vois même des des potes à moi qui sont
allés sur TF1 et je le dis voilà c'est
des gaz mer total excuse on dirait des
émissions des années 90 c'est des ils
font que des gazm fr pas direct sur les
autres chaînes déjà France font des gaz
M6 bon et la vérité ils ont fait une
émission la meilleure photo frère frère
la meilleure photo qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire la meilleure photo frère quand à
ça tu mets ça voilà alors ils vont
relancer l'île de la tentation on va
voir mais même l'Î la tentation ça va
être du pipicha par rapport à ça quand
tu vois ça et tu vas voir l'île de la
tentation derrière tu vas dire mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette de mer
mais franchement c'est vrai tu vois il
nous parle des 50 mais les 50 quoi les
50 ball les 50 non mais c'est vrai les
gars arrêtez c'est des trucs de gu ça
voilà ils ont ils ils ont tout tué c'est
fini ride ils ont fait ça tous les trucs
qui arrivent là et qui préparent et les
50 et les 51 et et même les voilà et
tout ce qu' prépar c'est des trucs de
gaz mer voilà on va pas se mentir vrai
ou pas
Pat on rardisé tous
les c'est pour ça et je le dis pas je
dis pas nous on a fait je dis je pense
vraiment et je pense vraiment nous un
moment dans le to show on a voilà on a r
gardé tout le monde aussi dis la vérité
tout le monde voula un son t PM
maintenant tout le monde va vouloir son
frenchy short mais je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui sur les chaînes adien ça
n'est pas possible tu as l'arcom qui va
passer derrière tu vas dire j'aime le
cul le cul le cul encore du cul tu du Do
dans ton cul je peux te dire que tu vas
te retrouver avec 6 millions d'amandes
ça va faire crique ça critique ça ça
critique ça mais des fois tu as des
programmes sur les chaînes atien moins
10 moi des fois je regarde des
programmes 10 je suis choqué sur des
programmes de - 10 qui passent sur TF1
sur M6 sur france télé y a des scènes de
violence des scènes de de de scènes
érotiqu où il y a il y a des a il y a
des coïes où les gens font l'amour bah
moi je suis choqué moins de 10 je dis je
dis franchement je suis choqué et là il
te trouve sur un truc privé que tu dois
aller voir toi-même avec un pictogramme
interdit moins de 18 ans tu es conscent
an on te dit ouais je suis choqué faut
interdire interdisait déjà le porno sur
les tablettes et sur les réseaux déjà et
puis Géraldine oui qu'est-ce qui se
passe non mais Géraldine disait tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait peut-être des
mauvais messages qui étaient passés aux
jeunes sur l'co ou la les préservatif et
C mais je te rappelle quand même oui non
mais je su avec toi non
mais je te critique pas Géraldine je dis
seulement que il y a aussi dans le
programme il y a pas de cigarette il y a
que les pipes il y a pas de cigarettes
[Rires]
dansère ça fait
Heiss
pas je vous dire en vérité ce qu' a eu
quelle est la téléréalité la plus tre
qu'on a eu c'est le LOF de 1 oui et le
loft 1 à côté de ça c'est Daniel dans un
film auoport euh je te le dis frère non
mais je vous le dis c'est c'est loft 1
quand tu avais vu les deux là dans la
piscine là Lana et et jeandouard qui qui
mixait sur Luana euh je peux te dire là
je peux te dire que et ça déjà c'était
le top du top depuis ils ont rien fait
de mieux et tu veux refaire ce qui qui a
fait ce qui a été fait il y a 20 ans qu'
a cartonné c'est mort les mecs regardez
tout le monde a évolué regardez euh de
la JAL
uam mais qu'est-ce qui a marqué dans
Qu'est-ce qui a marché dans le qui
marche là c'est la sincérité la
spontanéité et en fait FR est à la
télité ce que TPMP to parce qu'on parle
vrai il y a ce vrai ton qu'on voit sur
les réseaux sociaux quand on voit plein
d'émissions de télé aujourd'hui on est
dans le faux on parle pas comme dans la
vraie vie on a pas les mêmes sujets de
discussion on n' pas le même vocabulaire
eux ils se comportent comme des vrais
jeunes alors pas tous les jeunes
évidemment mais bien sûr que si c'est ça
la réalité aujourd'hui les jeunes il
cherchent ce ton là c'est ça c'est le
ton des réseaux c'est pas c'est pas les
trucs formatés àptisés que
our et puis on n'est pas ambassadeur de
quoi que ce soit on le dit moiême je
vouz faire quoi vous après là vous
voulez faire quoi bah la diffusion a
commencé il y a 15 jours je me laisse un
peu porter moi franchement je fais pas
mal d'interview j'aime bien voir ce côté
très militantisme par rapport au droit
de la femme au corps non mais c'est vrai
après on est rien dit j'ai pas dit que
CIT pas non mais et on espère qu'il
puisse avoir d'autres saisons après pour
le moment rien est fait on est encore
dans l'engouement de la première saison
donc on se laisse un petit peu porter
avec la nou moi je suis très content
voilà je suis très content parce que
c'est que c'est la tél téléréalité la
plus forte que tu es faite de loin ben
ah oui mais de loin encore une fois il y
a pas de comparaison possible y a pas de
comparaison Rapp que Antonin c'est le
boss de la ville et ça cartonne
absolument c'estàd que le nombre de vues
c'est
phamineuxamine et vous vous avez vu vos
followers sur insta ça a genre x 10 x
20ana à l'époque elle fait la couverture
de Libé elle fait la couverture de match
elle fait la couverture de mêmepo pas r
non mais juste pour savoir vous
concrètement est-ce que vos réseau par
exemple ils ont fait x 10 x 20 x 100 on
a tous pris beaucoup de followers après
on est quand même dans une aire du temps
où on prend moins de followers que les
premières saisons des anges ou des
choses comme ça où c'était quelque chose
d'incroyable on a tous pris quand même
beaucoup de followers en peu temps
comparé à d'autres télééalités où
c'était beaucoup plus te dire mais ça
c'est très bien mais les anges les
Marseillais tout ça c'était très bien à
l'époque très bienép c'était très bien
on va pas cracheressus c'était très bien
mais là aujourd'hui un mec qui veut
faire coiffeur à Miami j'en ai rien à
[__] don uneire de ciseau je dis
prends l'avion barre-toi j'ai pas suivre
non mais qu'est-ce j'en ai à [__]
prends des ciseaux et un pine et tu me
raconteras non mais franchement
qu'est-ce que j'en ai à tapé m à mèche
oui c'est pour c'est pour ça non il y a
rien mais c'est pour non mais c'est pour
ça que à mon avis par exemple la
ministre de la Culture qui dit c'est une
image catastrophique des rapports
humains elle a rien compris en dis elle
a même pas vu tu veux que je te dis mais
tu crois qu'elle vu c'est pire mais tu
crois quoi c'est elle est au concert de
Flut électronique avec Jean-Marc pitouli
non mais tu es grave qui mais tu crois
vraiment qu'elle a regardé ça la
ministre de la Culture frère c'est grave
pour des politiques parce qu'ils sont
déconnectés des jeunes déconnectés de la
modernité et même de l'évolution de la
société àav il est complètement
déconnecté et moi kiffe c'est que vous
soyez sur paround et qu' peuvent rien
faire rien faire contre vous ni la
ministre ni l'arcom ni rien du tout ça
c'est exceptionnel donc
continuez à faire des des cochonneries
là comme ça et des cochonnailles dans
toute la maison là et je peux vous dire
mais alors ce c'est surtout qu'elle a
elle prend le problème totalement à
l'envers parce que la ministre de la
Culture puis qu'elle veut interdire bon
pour les jeunes mais en réalité ça la
gêne vraiment elle a dit que c'était un
programme à la limite de la pornographie
et dans le même temps le gouvernement
comme
l'arcom veut essayer de combattre les
grosses plateformes comme Netflix et
cetera le problème c'est que l'arcom on
le sait mais il faut l'expliquer aux
gens euh passe des contrats avec des
chaînes linéaires en contraignant ces
chaînes à ne pas pouvoir faire un
certain nombre de programmes qui sont
autorisés sur les plateformes donc ce
qui va se passer c'est qu'on donne en
réalité en faisant ça plus de pouvoir
aux plateformes et moins au CH là tu
peux pas ce jeux dire c'est bon question
oui non mais dis pas n'importe quoi
aussi arrête là tu dis n'importe quoi en
tant que G Verdez je te dis nimp
excuse-moi Jacques mais l'arcom
écoute-moi bien l'arcom ils sont faits
pour pour s'occuper de la télévision les
pauvres tu peux pas les mettre partout
ils sont fait pour les chaînes linéires
sinon tu crées un autre truc et un autre
truc qui va s'occuper de ça mais là
l'arcom peuvent pas être partout déjà
qu' font ça l'arcom à un moment moi
aussi voilà il faut arrêter de leur
taper dessus l'arcom ils peuvent pas
être partout ils vont pas s'occuper de
ça c'est pas dans leur compét non mais
c'est pas dans leur compét c'est au
gouvernement peut-être de créer un un
nouveau BA voilà c'est tout bon en tout
cas merci vous avez plein les deux je
déjà minist pour la ministre la ministre
se plein de ce qu'elle a dit elle a dit
c'est limite pour qui c'est limite la
pornographie alors on va au bout on
arrête la pornographie on interdit la
pornographie viens dire va pas au bout
pour alors pourquoi elle fait ça
pourquoi elle va pas au bout parelle pe
pas alors pourquoi elle fait une sortie
comme ça quand tu peux pas moi je peux
pas rouler en Ferrari je dis pas tout le
monde que je roule en Ferrari quand tu
peux pas faire les choses ferme-la si tu
sa si tu peux pas faire les choses ttoi
parce que là c'est des sorties à de
balles de
dire donc si tu peux pas le faire le
fais pas merci merci qu'est-ce qu'on
peut vous souhaitez bonne année la ré en
êes où alors vous avez un mec ou pas je
peux pas dire sinon je un petit peu pour
regarder les épisodes ouais donc en tout
cas elle est intenable ah ouais j'adore
l'utre il est incroyable en est
inablei c'est le C ligac du
cul elle est croocante estante je te dis
elle est je peux te dire je peux te dire
j'ai sorti mon piment despelett je peux
te
dire il est incroyable merci à tous les
deux merci